ماذا تعرف عن الوضع في
الجنوب الآن بعد أن فر العديد من الفلسطينيين
بالآلاف والآلاف من
الشمال؟ ماذا لو كانت هناك أي موارد
لاستيعاب الأعلاف أو حتى تقديم
المياه لهم نعم أعني مايكل وأعتقد أنه
يمكننا وصف الوضع حقًا  بما
أن الوضع على وشك الكارثة أه
فهو وخيم جدًا في جميع أنحاء أه غزة
أم نحن نعلم أنه كانت هناك
مستويات عالية من العنف كما أه
زميلك ذكر أه أكثر من 2000 حالة وفاة
الآن ربما ما يقرب من 8000
إصابة خطيرة أيضًا أم لدينا  أه
المستشفيات والعيادات لا
تعمل أه أه بشكل جيد أو
تعمل جزئيا فقط لذلك وهي
مثقلة بالصدمات الزائدة
وطبعا أه قلة الوقود
قلة الكهرباء فقدان بعض
الموظفين قلة الماء  أه وانخفاض
المخزون الطبي يجعل من
الصعب جدًا توفير تلك الرعاية لعدد
الحالات الإضافية والآن كما
تشير إلى ذلك مع كل هذا
الاكتظاظ أه خاصة مع
التحركات السكانية الأخيرة إلى
جنوب غزة، أه حقًا
نهيئ أنفسنا لكارثة
اكتظاظ حالة الصحة العامة أه في
هذه المراكز الجماعية والمدارس أه سوء
الصرف الصحي سوء الوصول إلى المياه أه
فرصة كبيرة لتفشي الأمراض
أه ثم لديك بُعد الصحة العقلية
أيضًا لذا فهو من
منظور الصحة العامة هذا
تقريبًا  سيء كما هو الحال، نعم، كما تعلم، لقد
زرت غزة عدة مرات،
أعني أن الوضع ليس جيدًا أبدًا هناك، أعني أنه ليس
أبدًا، أعني أن
البنية التحتية تتأرجح دائمًا على
الحافة، ومن الصعب تخيل مدى تأثير
ذلك  عندما لا يكون لديك
طعام ووقود ومياه وهكذا،
قالت وزارة الصحة الفلسطينية إن
المستشفيات التي تعلم أنها فقدت
الأدوية السريرية الخاصة بها، أعني عندما
ينفد الوقود،
يمكن أن
تنهار غرف العمليات بشكل جيد نعم أعني أنه أه أه
حقًا  ممتدة إلى حافة الهاوية الآن
أممم لذلك نحن حقًا بحاجة إلى
هذه الممرات الإنسانية التي
كان الناس يتحدثون عنها منذ أيام
وأه أولئك الذين لديهم كما تعلمون آه
سلطة اتخاذ القرار آه تعلمون
لا يسهلون ذلك أم  نحن فقط
بحاجة إلى فتح هذه الحدود الأكثر وعورة في أسرع وقت ممكن،
نحتاج إلى الوصول إليها من أي مكان ممكن اه
كما تعلم أننا بحاجة إلى تجديد
المخزون الطبي الذي نحتاجه للوقود اه
نحن بحاجة إلى تدفق المياه النظيفة مرة أخرى اه اه
اعني وسوف يستغرق الأمر وقتًا  لقد استغرق الأمر
وقتًا طويلاً لإعادة هذا النظام الصحي إلى
وضعه الطبيعي، لكن هذه أوقات عصيبة،
وهذه الممرات الإنسانية
ضرورية للغاية، ولا يقتصر الأمر على مجرد
توصيل الإمدادات عبر الحدود
على الرغم من أننا بحاجة إلى تأمين هذه الممرات
في جميع أنحاء غزة حتى نتمكن من الوصول إلى
الأشخاص المستضعفين المحتاجين، نعم،
يمكنك إدخالهم إلى قطاع غزة
ثم يتعين عليك توزيعهم، وهذا
صحيح تمامًا أنا أنا أتساءل
ما هي الخيارات المتاحة لأولئك الذين
سخنوا التحذير  للتوجه جنوبًا، أعني
أنه من المحتمل أنك تعرف 100200300000
شخص ذهبوا إلى الجنوب
الذي كان يعاني بالفعل من الفقر المدقع،
ليس الأمر كما لو أن هناك مباني سكنية فارغة
لهم أو أو
بنية تحتية لإطعامهم أو أو سقائهم
أيضًا.  ماذا يمكن أن يحدث
إذا كان هناك تفشي
للمرض، حسنًا، سيكون من
الصعب جدًا السيطرة عليه، كما تعلم أن
الأمراض التي تقلقنا كثيرًا
هي مرض آه وأنت
تعرف الأشخاص الذين لا يستطيعون
الوصول إليها  المياه النظيفة آه، يعاني الأطفال من
سوء التغذية هناك، لذا آه،
قد يكون تفشي الإسهال
مميتًا آه خاصة بالنسبة
للأشخاص الضعفاء مثل كبار السن و و و
الأطفال الصغار الذين سيقلقون بشأن الآخرين آه
كما تعلم الالتهاب الرئوي والتهابات الفيروسية الأخرى
التي  يمكن أن ينتشر اه من خلال
ما نسميه نقل القطرات، ومن
ثم فإن القدرة على التغلب على
هذه الأنواع من حالات التفشي قد تم استنفادها بشكل
لا يصدق، لذلك اه أنت تعلم أن الكثير
من الناس يمكن أن يموتوا
وبالتأكيد هناك.  سيكون هناك الكثير من المعاناة